where are we we are on problem 15
problem 15 I'll do that yellow from 15
and we'll see they have a bunch of
triangles drawn so let me get the line
tool and see what I can do about drawing
these so I've got a big triangle that
looks something like that it's the big
triangle and there's this altitude that
drops down drops down like that and
there's a smaller triangle within it
that looks something like this something
like this this is the smaller triangle
and then this is a 90-degree angle right
here it's perpendicular q s P V oh my
god I messed up let's see how far I
could let's see i would have to erase
some i should have done this ahead of
time I'm wasting your time but bear with
me I drew this line wrong this line does
something different that line looks like
this looks like this all right now I'm
back in business
excuse me if I burp I just ate an apple
okay I'm wasting your time T and then
our took me almost two minutes just to
draw this thing and it says no to figure
not drawn to scale it says in triangle
pqr above q s / QV q s / q v is equal to
one-third and it says PT / PR is equal
to three fourths what is the value of
the fraction and they want to know area
of triangle PST / area of triangle pqr
now let's see what we can do have been
thinking just yet I've just been drawing
and writing so they say q s q s / q v
over this whole thing is one-third fair
enough and they say PT PT / PR is equal
to three fourths okay fair enough so
area of PST / area of P Q R so what's
the area of PST PST so area of triangle
PST that would be just the base times
the height times one-half right one half
and we'll see that the one has canceled
out we don't have to do them but I'll do
it just to figure it out so it's one
half and PT one half PT x 0 1 half PT x
sv and then area
area of area of P Q R is going to be one
half so it's this whole thing PR PR x QV
all right times Q V so the area of this
triangle PST over the area of triangle
pqr well it's just going to be one half
PT x sv over one half times the area of
P Q R so it's over this one half p r x
QV and let's see what we could figure
out we definitely see the one halves
cancel out and well do we know what PT /
PR is let me see PT / PR PT / PR they
give it right here PT / PR is
three-fourths so this this is this term
is equal to three fourths so this is
equal to 3 / 4 x sv / QV and now we're
the conundrum we know what QV is right
we only know qsr we don't know sv but
let me ask you a question if q s if q s
/ QV over this whole thing is one-third
so this distance this this pink distance
right here let's pick this this is one
third of this entire length right
because this distance over the entire
distance one third then sv over QV so
then this is going to be two thirds
right if this is one-third this will be
two thirds so then we know that sv
that's what we're trying to figure out
here sv over the whole thing is going to
be two thirds so this is two thirds and
then three four times two-thirds well
the threes cancel out and you get two
fourths it equals one half
and you just fill it in next problem
hope you get that most of it we just
figured out what the areas were and just
substitute it and then we just have to
figure out what sv / q v is given Q s /
QV right and we knew that we figured out
that s P or Q V is two thirds I hope I
did not confuse you it's Thanksgiving
and it's not a good day to confuse
people okay number 16 16 let the
function H be defined by this I enjoy
these h of x is equal to 14 plus x
squared over 4 if H of 2 m is equal to 9
m so it tells us that H of 2 m is equal
to 9 m what is one possible value of M
well let's just do figure out what H of
2mm is so H of 2m if we put it into that
H of 2 m is equal to just using this
definition of its function 14 plus 0
we're taking H of 2m so it's 2m squared
2m squared over 4 and we also know that
this is equal to 9 m right and let's see
what we can do to simplify it so we
could say 14 plus 4m squared over 4 just
squaring both of these is equal to 9
this cancels out right and then we r 0
is equal to 9 m sorry and now we're left
with 14 plus M squared is equal to 9 m
we're left with a quadratic it might not
be obvious to you let's subtract 9 m
from both sides and rearrange a little
bit you get M squared minus 9 m plus 14
is equal to 0 it is i took this m9 input
on this side so in fact 29 m from both
sides and put the M Squared out for
front now we have a quadratic and we
need to solve figure out
where this expression intersects the
x-axis or figure out the roots of this
quadratic and we can factor this right
if you remember your factoring from
later algebra one or some algebra to
this would be M minus seven times M
minus 2 is equal to 0 and how did I
figure that out well I had to figure out
two numbers that when i multiply them
equals positive 14 and then when I Adam
is equal to negative 9 right so 14 9
well 7 times 2 is 14 or negative 7 times
negative 2 is also 14 and we know it's
negative because I have to go to
negative 9 and that's just a review of
what you learned in algebra class if
this was confusing you might want to
review factoring anyway if M minus seven
times n minus 2 is equals zero that
means that m is equal to seven or two
and you can fill in either one of those
because they say what is one possible
value for M I have a minute left so and
oh boy only had two problems left well
that's good for one extra video so I'll
see you in the next video